só usa mais um vídeo ensinando como
fazer e essa é a nossa equipe que
disparam balas de papel como é a índia
deu é uma versão avançada do que os
encerramentos aqui um pequeno melhor
imagem do tempo nesta página que tinham
estamos também está a enfrentar mais
simples e muito mais tempo durante o
cantora que já não tenho relação à
última música dessa maneira explicou o
técnico mais bonita 34 fica muito melhor
arma vai ficar mesmo com várias
dimensões vão compreender tudo da forma
que estou fazendo aqui agora
[Música]
você tiver dificuldades ou por uma pausa
no final quando terá tura cima da arma
conseguem visualizar a arma entregue ou
seja uma vistoria e dar usar uma cola
quente para colar os tubos mas vocês
podem tentar utilizar com outras escolas
mas eu aconselho a cola quente porque
ela deixa muita cola e arma vai ficar
muito mais resistente por ser aqui uns
pedaços numa folha tamanho a3
vou fazer uma visita mais pequena isso
porque parecia rifa deslizo livramento
dentro do tubo que fiz anteriormente o
melhor é muito importante porque quando
a gente tiver apostado em ser aquela
parte do vídeo traz agora vou juntar
dois políticos desolado usando uma super
cola deixar ficar um pouco agora é muito
importante mas não tem muito nova para
fazer esta abertura é muito boa então
vai ficar sem o maiô rasgado papel até
aí vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda para
vocês fazerem como adulta cai
vocês viram que eu fiz um buraco usando
uma furadeira por dentro do projeto
pelado movimento uma continuidade seja
mais uma linha que vai do cano e
continuando por cima dos políticos
depois de atirar e cortar usando uma
serra para metal
no quarto e cultura porque ela estraga
um pouco então nós temos com uma serra
que implantou podem usar aquela grande
tamanho só acontece porque nessa que
nome é usada para cortar tubos de pvc
aquela grande também certo
agora vou juntar três folhas com o
tamanho a3
agora vejam um lado eu estou colar é
para o maior das folhas usar agora três
folhas porque o carro tem ficar muito
resistente e de forma testou posicionar
as folhas no cano vai ficar grande
agora eu vou utilizar estava aqui de
madeira mas vocês podem usar a realizar
entre a mãe e outro da vara porque é
mais fácil uma vez que ela é toda igual
de um lado a outro do green no lado a
outro
no final pode bater um pouco tudo na
mesa desta vez consegui fazer mesmo
tempo foi precificado bater vai ficar
ligeiramente saída pelos lados é só
bater na mesa para alinhar tudo agora
vejam x é igual é que o espaço adentro
que fica sem nada ou seja dentro do tubo
é o chile vai depender do que vai fazer
esse programa caí um cartão mas eu não
vou deixar de ir ao mercado vai ficar
é muito importante a outra vez com o
militar pedindo dar uma lâmina banho
fiada porque tem várias camadas de
folhas também não foi boa então vai
rasgar tudo começar a primeira vez porém
crianças peçam ajuda ao mundo que aborto
é uma espécie da operação caixa de
fósforos colados práxedis depois colocar
do outro a tombar
o barão claro o resto das espécies na
parte dos tubos que é bastante simples
basta vocês olharem para o sangue
se você quiser fazer outra arma podem
usar o mesmo sistema e depois é só
alterar os tubos que estão lá por uma
questão de estética
é muito importante esta parte da região
ficou em 5 turbo usando uma folha o
tamanho a4 normais você tem em casa um
pouco a guarda mas também aumenta muito
então é uma coisa que praticamente não
existem
mark van bommel também cola nesta parte
de trás para manter a distância para
andar e eternizado no tubo que não tem
cofre até 100 certo fazer uma folha de
tamanho a3 e que vocês conseguem ver que
não tem duas coisas que o tamanho a4
fazer uma rifa também a 3 porque é muito
difícil encontrar as folhas tamanho a3
coloridas então o que perguntar tamanho
a4 contornar a volta fica muito bonito e
também aumenta bastante a existência
desta parte de trás que é muito
diferente
eu vou largar ela um pouco para ficar
por dentro
nós confiamos palmar e fazer esta tira
que vai ser mais fácil do brasil uma vez
que as obras são mais apertados
vocês já podem abusar na cola porque
agora responde como deve ser
já vai ficar bom
na parte final ajuda bastante para
manter o cargo no fim deu certo e agora
já tinha feito outras 50 63 é idêntica
eu consegui anteriormente eu já tinha
feito só para não ficar essa semana para
ver se vai fazer esta parte da frente
dos óculos da marca de anualmente esta
arma e ela é muito mais no tempo que as
outras coisas anteriormente fará um
balanço do papel
isso porque as outras que eu fiz todas
as folhas com o tamanho a4 e essas usar
folhas com o tamanho a3 mais então ficou
muito mas mesmo muito mais resistente
que as anteriores
agora eu vou retirar uma parte da folha
com tamanha 3
isto é para fazer um pistão da arma como
estão treinando livramento
convém que eu fique ligeiramente mais
que nunca refaria 31 perto em bairros e
rolando e no final é só aprender com
fita em tudo que tem mais ou menos 23
centros e também do tubo não é ser muito
importante ter calma vamos partir com
isso
veja como textura é ver o tamanho léo
agora dobre o chefe desta forma para
cima e quase na risca quando acaba o
tubo que vocês usarem usar aqui dois
elásticos um lado e dois do outro lado e
vou juntar os porque não sei como
assintantes arma já um pouco preso então
com vai juntar andar por um elástico
canteiros e num buzinão força porque
esta manhã a arma do papel a cair muito
importante você entender esta parte com
fita e não concordo porque vocês usarem
cola com o impacto da arma
a cola vai se aprendendo aos poucos e
passado alguns disparos
vai ser a cola e que vai se fazer então
é muito importante vocês usarem fita e
não cola e eu fiz isso estamos a brincar
bastante com essa arma e ela ainda não
se entregou e está intacta
acho que fiz agora cinco segundos
tenho três pequenos e dois grandes
estou agora o colar dois clínicos e
depois destes dois prémios popular no
meio do grande
agora do outro lado temos um pequeno eo
grande votarão maio
erika que só tem duas camadas vai ficar
em cima está em três camadas vai ficar
na parte de baixo do carro vencedor para
no cartão que vocês usarem um carregador
é muito importante que seja daqui é
obeso que desliza facilmente cair não
pode ser perigoso todos os atores
políticos por quatro vai ser muito
grande não vai funcionar tão bem até aí
seja é aquilo que ela estágios triais
que na moça funcionou muito bem que elas
são bem visíveis a quem não podem usar
dessas não comprar cartão com meu filho
podem ver estou claro aquilo tem três
camadas em baixa e tem só duas camadas
fica em cima e com podem ver o elástico
o mesmo bonito
antigamente o elástico passava por cima
da arma passar por baixo do credor e
ficaram bastante foi agora desta forma
fica muito mais apresentava eu gosto
trabalhar uma arma nova que vocês vão
adorar que é um carregador bem de frente
o que é catorze sai para fora a bola de
léo sai disparada depois de esgotar o
disparo é cápsula sai fora do corredor é
muito difícil mesmo vai dar mais
trabalho a fazer isso é muito importante
vocês têm que pôr super cola nesta
espaço aqui para endurecer que não
passei super cola porque só estou é
mostrado basicamente por nessas três
partidas para ficar rígido e aguentado
com o impacto do pistão fazer as balas
vamos ter 40 do século xxi um lado e
três quintos do outro lado e usar equipe
folha tamanho a3
nós a internet por theo mas não foi
muito fácil mas estou a folha em
comprimento
[Música]
e você tem que regular da parte maior
para parto mais pequena e por camus dois
tamanhos diferentes à medida que ela ter
ganho no ano vai fazendo formato de
balas e fica aquela parte cônica ali à
frente para finalizar é só usar cola cva
e claro com de serraria muito importante
a união super cola na ponta da arma e
serve para evitar que a bola se o
estrago com os espaços
[Música]
espero que vocês tenham instalado em
breve vamos ter uma nova geração de
armas mais lista em que quando ar muito
clara calcula paiva foto arq comandar
banda no canal e banco do brasil